My son was just diagnosed with bacterial pneumonia.
He's 13 years old.
I declined a chest x-ray,
but the doctor said because one lung sounded
full and crackly that it was likely bacterial
and they are seeing tons of it right now.
They prescribed Z-pack and I know the holistic world
really frills about antibiotics in general
and I always try to avoid them impossible,
especially with my children.
I worry about the antibiotics,
but also worry about not treating them.
Viral resolves on its own,
but bacterial is a different story.
What is your opinion about a zisleromyosin?
Do you think it is relatively safe
with few side effects and adverse reactions?
I just don't know what to do.
I value and trust your opinion
above all other doctors.
Oh, that's nice.
So I wanted your take on it
and thank God it's Wednesday.
Okay, so I said before that bacterial infections
part something you necessarily want to play with for too long.
So you want to look at signs and symptoms.
So understand, if you just go,
every time you get an infection,
even if a bacterial infection,
if you just go run and get an antibiotic all the time,
then you're not allowing your body to go through a TH1,
a TH2 immune reaction.
And that TH2 B cell reaction is where you make antibodies
against the pathogen.
If in the past,
I remember back in the 80s and 90s,
people would run their kids to the pediatrician
for the sniffles and they'd be given antibiotics like candy.
And the danger of that is the child,
never made their child's immune system
never created antibodies to that infection,
to that strap or whatever it was.
And if that doesn't take place,
now you don't have circulated antibodies against that bacteria.
So if you don't have circulated antibodies
against that bacteria,
well, then you could get it again and again and again and again
and you have no defense against it.
So there's a benefit to not go away and run it
and just jump in on the antibiotic platform too quickly.
There's also a risk.
So an antibiotic will kill a bacterial infection.
And if the bacterial infection goes on too long,
you know, it could create greater levels of morbidity.
So you have to be the judge of that your child or your,
you're dealing with something with yourself.
You have to be judge of your tolerance level
and, you know, how, what are you're going to be able to handle
this disease and if you're, if your own immune system
is going to be able to overcome it or not.
So I'm always in favor of, you know,
if I feel like I'm coming down with something
and it could be a bacterial infection,
I will try to fight it off with natural things
as much as possible without taking it in antibiotic.
I haven't taken antibiotics for many things.
Now if my suspect did something like Lyme disease,
I had a tick, I found a tick ahead of Bullseye reaction,
I would take it antibiotic immediately.
I would not wait, I would not try to let my immune system
fight it off.
That's a whole other discussion.
But in this kind of case, like this,
you got to look at the general health of your 13 year old,
if your 13 year old is super thin
and, you know, doesn't have a lot of mass to them
to be able to lose weight during an infection or something,
you know, you, you got to be concerned about that too.
So I'm not against antibiotic use.
Side note, if you do take an antibiotic,
make sure you take a probiotic with the antibiotic.
There's been plenty of studies out there
that show if you take probiotics with antibiotics,
you greatly reduce the negative effects
of the antibiotic to the microbiota.
So make sure you do that.
So I can't tell you to take or not to take an antibiotic,
but you know, just knowing those parameters,
my kids got a really bad fever, he's coffee,
well you certainly don't, you know,
want them to get so bad that,
that, you know, his recovery time's gonna be great,
but you also want him to develop antibiotic.
So it's a balance that you have to work through
as a parent, it's a balance that you work through with yourself.
So I wish I could give you a better answer.
Yes, or no, for sure, but I wouldn't be there.